GOPI KALLAYIL: Good afternoon.
My name is Gopi Kallayil.
And I'm delighted to
welcome to the Google
campus for the fourth
time Radhanath Swami,
the author of the international
bestseller "The Journey Home"
and now the "New York
Times" bestseller,
"The Journey Within."
I had my first
opportunity to learn
about Radhanath Swami of all the
things in a video about Burning
Man.
He does get around to the
most interesting of places.
But during the
Burning Man interview
in response to a
question, he said,
everybody's looking
for happiness.
And in search of the happiness,
we change your externalities.
Whereas, to find
true happiness, we
need to shift our consciousness.
And the way Radhanath
Swami reached
this very important
insight was through
his own personal journey,
where when he was 19 years old,
he left Chicago.
And in search of what is the
source of true happiness,
he hitchhiked his way across
Europe, Central Asia, all
the way to India
and arrived there
on the borders with no money.
And they would not let him in.
And he persuaded them
to allow him to come in.
And he said you would do
something for humanity
at large and, particularly,
for the people of India.
But during the course
of his journey,
what he realized that the
cost for most problems in life
was human frailties that happen
irrespective of who you are
and what your background is.
And he's committed
himself to really studying
human consciousness, the
relationship between people,
and how that can be
a source of happiness
if you approach
it the right way.
And in exploring
all of these issues
with very little
resources-- as a monk,
he has no bank
account, no money.
But he's managed to persuade
a large group of people
to work alongside him and create
several humanitarian projects
around the world, including
a midday meal program that
feeds 1.2 million children
every school day in India,
ecovillage outside Mumbai,
a hospital that provides
free or low cost holistic care,
and a number of other projects
like that around the world,
demonstrating to us that, more
than resources, it is like an
inner commitment that comes
from somewhere deep within,
as the path of yoga dicted,
that can really allow us to
manifest our fullest potential.
And here to discuss
more about this topic
and to explore this with
us-- his own journey,
as well as what it
means in our lives--
please help me
welcome to the stage
at Google for the fourth
time Mr. Radhanath Swami.
[APPLAUSE]
RADHANATH SWAMI: (CHANTING)
I'm very grateful to be
with all of you today.
Thank you, Gopi, for
opening the doors
to this world-renowned,
most influential institution
of Goggle for me to share
some thoughts with you.
And my sincere gratitude to
each and every one of you
who has come today.
I was asked to speak on
the subject of the currency
of relationships.
Generally, we think of currency
as a medium for exchange,
as a means of expressing
what has value.
And so often in
the world today, we
underestimate the
currency of relationships,
because we become distracted
from what we really
want to achieve in our life.
Emerson wrote that
the reason why
this world is in so
much chaos and conflict
with so much dissatisfaction is
because people are disconnected
from their own selves.
What is happiness?
What are we really looking for?
The tendency, not
only today, but always
throughout human history
is that we become so
distracted toward things that
are relatively superficial,
and we lose our scope of what's
really important in life.
There's an analogy I
learned in South India.
There's a fish--
I'm sorry, there's
a bird called the crane--
white feathers, long beak,
stands on one leg in a stream
of water, looking down for food.
And so many little
fish are passing--
dozens and dozens of little
fish, hundreds of little fish,
thousands of little fish.
The crane observes,
lets them pass.
When a big fish comes [GULP],
he eats it and feasts.
Now, I don't eat fish.
But the analogy is appropriate.
He's keeping his
attention focused
on what is actually
significant and lets
all the little things go.
Unless we are focused on
the higher principles,
the more valuable things
that are really in our lives,
then we're easily distracted
by every single little fish.
And we never find the big one.
It's so easy to see a
little pebble as a mountain,
unless we're focused
on a real mountain,
because [NON-ENGLISH],
everyone is seeking pleasure,
everyone is seeking meaning.
Unless we're focused
on deep issues,
then we will be obsessed
with little things.
And this is especially
true with relationships.
I often cite an example of
my own mother and father.
When I was about
eight years old,
my mother told me, as I
was sitting on her bed,
that everyone loves your
father and everyone loves me,
but we do not love each other.
We have decided we're
going to separate.
Now, as a little child, I
couldn't even fathom that idea.
My parents don't love each
other, and they're separating?
I was so disoriented, so
broken hearted by hearing that,
that I couldn't say a word.
I just sat and cried.
My mother was shocked
to see my reaction.
She didn't know what to say.
And I got up, and I ran out
the door, down the hall,
down the stairs, through the
living room, out the door,
and ran for blocks and blocks,
and hid in some bushes.
This was almost 60 years ago.
I waited a few hours.
And then I saw my father's
car coming down the road.
And I knew he was coming home.
And I knew my mother was going
to tell him what happened
and my reaction.
So after he went in
the door, I secretly
snuck in the back door.
And when he went into his
bedroom to meet my mother
and they closed the
door, I secretly
put my ear to the
door, because I
wanted to hear what they
were going to discuss.
My mother told my father what
she said and what happened.
There was complete silence.
And then I heard them both say,
for the sake of our children,
we are going to make this work.
It wasn't easy for them.
They struggled, but they
had a higher principle
than their own disagreements.
They had a big fish to focus on.
And over the years, it was
hard work for them, I know,
but I saw perhaps the most
united, loving relationship
between two people
that I had seen.
They earned it by focusing
on the higher principle.
They let all the
little things pass.
And my own guru,
Srila Prabhupada, I
remember he was giving
a talk at a marriage.
And he gave an analogy
about Mahatma Gandhi.
He said-- he's quoting from
Mahatma Gandhi's autobiography
I believe-- one time,
Gandhi and his wife
had a serious argument.
And Gandhi got angry and
said, get out from here.
So his wife left.
And she sat out on
the street in front
of the house for some hours.
And then Gandhi came out, and
he saw his wife still there.
And he says, what are
you still doing here?
And she said, I
have nowhere to go.
And he said, all right,
let's just forget it.
And she said, yes,
let's just forget.
And Srila Prabhupada explained,
when we have disagreements,
if we have a higher purpose that
we're recognizing of why we're
together, then we can
easily, or maybe not
easily, but we
understand the necessity
of forgetting all these
little things, somehow
or other adjusting.
I left college
after one semester,
so I don't know too much
about technology or medicine.
But as far as I know, when
you're developing electronics,
there's conductors
and superconductors
and semiconductors,
so that the current
can flow in an
effective way to fulfill
the purpose of that device
without overheating,
without conflict between
the different components.
That type of circuitry is
required in our relationships
with each other.
Ultimately, things can
give some pleasure,
some fulfillment to the body and
to the senses and to the mind,
but not to the heart.
Essentially, people
are looking for love.
Only love can give
fulfillment to the heart.
And that flow of
love, like the heart
itself, pumps blood
and receives blood.
But if there's plaque
in the arteries,
then the flow both
within and out
of the heart is blocked--
the plaque of selfish desires
of false ego or arrogance, when
it blocks our ability to love
and experience love.
The principle of yoga, the
principle of spirituality,
the true quality of humanity
is when we learn how to love
and how to be loved.
I was seeing Gopi's
book about "The Internet
to the Inner-Net."
And it's a brilliant conception.
And Gopi is a person who has
realization and experience,
seeing the world, how
the things, whether it's
technology, strength,
intelligence,
it can develop into a great
benefit or a great danger,
depending on us.
A knife is neither good or bad.
It's determined by
who has that knife.
A thief will use the
knife to kill someone,
to take what they have.
And a doctor will use the same
knife to save a person's life.
Our bodies, our wealth, our
science, our technology,
our currency of
economics, everything
is potentially either
destructive or constructive
for the well-being of ourselves
and others or for the opposite,
according to what's
within our own hearts.
The ecology today,
there's so much pollution.
Why?
Because people's
hearts are polluted.
You cannot really sustainably
clean up the ecology
of the world until we learn to
clean the ecology of the human
heart.
Greed, insatiable,
selfishness, arrogance--
as long as that's there,
the pollution within will
manifest as the pollution
in our relationships
and in the
environment around us.
The concept of yoga
or spirituality
is cleansing the
ecology of the heart,
learning to help one another to
focus and unite on the really
higher meaningful principles.
Srila Prabhupada, my
teacher, gave an example.
If you throw a stone in
the middle of a pond,
the circles that
come out will all
be harmonious with each other.
But if throw different
stones in different parts
of the same pond, all
the different circles
will collide, because they
have a different center point.
Yes, there are different
religions in this world,
and there are different races,
and different nationalities,
and different people with
different occupational
tendencies in different
roles in society.
But what do we all
have in common?
What is this higher principle?
Who are we?
It's very difficult to
see the unity among us
unless we really have
something to unify.
In the Bible, it is
said, what profiteth
the person who gains
the whole world
but loses their eternal soul.
It also says that
the first commandment
is to love God with all your
heart, mind, and a soul.
And the natural
byproduct of that is you
will love your
neighbor as yourself.
And you'll recognize everyone
of all races, of all religions,
of all species is our neighbor.
In the "Bhagavad Gita," there
is the same principle stated.
[NON-ENGLISH], that true
knowledge is when we see with
equal vision the higher
principle of what
our relationship is with others,
when we understand who we are.
Am I this body, or
am I in this body?
Am I this mind, or
am I witnessing life
through this mind?
These are serious
questions that are rarely
pondered in today's world.
The beginning of true
spiritual knowledge
in all various traditions
is to understand who am I
and what is my
relationship with others.
The "Bhagavad Gita"
tells [NON-ENGLISH],
that we are the atma, the living
force that is seeing through
the eyes and tasting
through the tongue,
and hearing through the ears.
The nature of that
spirit is it is
beyond birth and beyond death.
It is a part of God.
And every living being
is of the same source.
When we actually connect
to the truth of who we are,
we can understand our
relationship with others.
The nature of life itself,
the nature of the soul
is to love and to experience the
infinite love of the Supreme,
to be an instrument
of that love.
When that is the principle,
that is our focus,
then we can remain
united with respect
under all of the various stormy
conditions of this world.
This building is very beautiful.
But it's only here because
there's a foundation.
Without that foundation,
however architecturally pleasing
a structure may be, when the
storm comes, it will collapse.
What is the foundation of
our own state of being?
What is the
foundational principle
of our occupation, our
family relationships,
in our interactions with the
environment and the world?
When we have a strong
inner foundation,
when we find that peace,
that inner fulfillment,
that inner love, that is
within us that is our nature,
then whatever
temptations or fears may
come in life, whatever storms
may appear, we remain strong.
We remain stable.
We remain focused on
what is really important.
There are limitless reasons to
fight, to disagree, to hate.
But there is one really special
important reason to respect,
to love, and to
live with integrity,
because that is truth.
That is what is pleasing to
God, however we may know.
And that is the only way we can
find meaning and fulfillment
in our lives.
What is within us is expressed.
And I'll end with one little
story that I love to tell.
Years ago, I was sitting on
the bank of the river Ganges.
It was a summer day.
And because it was a summer
day, this is in India,
it was probably 110
degrees Fahrenheit.
There was no one around.
It was just me.
There wasn't a cloud in the sky.
It was burning hot.
And I was eager to
go in the river.
But first, I wanted to sit and
meditate for a few minutes.
And I saw over my head,
there was a huge hawk.
His brown feathers were
shining in the sun.
He had yellow eyes
that were glistening,
very sharp claws and beak.
And he was looking down.
He was right over my
head, maybe about 20 feet.
And he was circling lower
and lower and lower.
I kept looking up.
And it looked like he was
looking at me, because there
was no one else around.
I said a little prayer.
Suddenly, [WHOOSH] he
dove right into the river
just a few feet in front
of me and was underwater.
There was a skirmish, and then
he came out from the river.
And in his claws was a
fish about a foot long.
And because it was
so close to me,
I could see the eyes
of that little fish.
He looked so bewildered.
He looked so disoriented.
And I was thinking that this
little fish was probably
going about his day
like every other day,
swimming up stream, swimming
downstream, swimming
across stream, maybe
with his family of fish,
looking for food, playing.
Suddenly, at the least expected
moment, the hawk of fate
ripped him right out
of his ordinary life.
And he was flapping desperately
as the hawk carried him
further and further and
further into the forest.
I was thinking what, am I
supposed to learn from this?
Like that little fish,
we go about our life.
But at any moment, we could be
ripped out of our complacency.
We read about it.
We hear about it.
It's happened to us.
But if that fish
was swimming deeper,
the hawk could not reach it.
And similarly, when we find
our meaning, our purpose,
and our fulfillment within
ourselves in a deeper way,
and when our relationships
are focused in a deeper way
for a higher purpose, then
the inevitable changes of this
world, the sunny days
and the stormy days,
cannot to starve us.
Humanity is based
on the principle
of brotherhood and sisterhood.
But on the physical level,
it's very superficial.
It is in the brotherhood
and sisterhood of life,
on the basis of the
depth of our own souls,
beyond sectarian concepts that
we can understand our unity
and the necessity of that unity.
When we keep focused
on higher principles,
we can easily adjust
and effectively
deal with the
circumstances around us.
If we're depending on
our unity and depending
on our inner fulfillment
on those circumstances--
and so much is
beyond our control--
it is simply unsustainable.
Great leaders help people
to unite on these higher
principles-- parents, political
leaders, spiritual leaders,
leaders within various
types of companies.
And the highest,
deepest connection
comes from learning how to love.
Love is an expression
of the heart.
Love is when we value
unselfish service
for the well-being of others.
Compassion is the natural
expression of a loving heart.
It's the greatest
need in the world
today in all of our companies
and all of our relationships
to learn the value
of compassion.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
The question is, does the world
create consciousness or does
consciousness create the world?
In the Vedic literatures,
there is a particular book that
is called the "Brahma Sutra."
It is the summary of the essence
of a huge body of literature
dealing with so many
various subject matters.
And the first verse
is [NON-ENGLISH],
that everything is
coming from one source.
That source has many names--
Bhagavan, Para Brahman, God,
Krishna.
We understand that
ultimately everything
is coming from the ultimate
state of consciousness,
the cause of all causes.
And everything is
within material nature
is orchestrated by
that Supreme conscious.
In our own little
bodies, we grow
because there is consciousness.
At the beginning, the father
and the mother come together,
and there's a little tiny seed.
And it begins to grow, because
there's consciousness there.
And it grows into
a little embryo.
And then it's born,
it's a little infant.
Then it becomes a
baby, and then it
grows through childhood
throughout adolescence,
through middle age, old age.
When that conscious
force leaves the body,
there's no more growth.
There's only dwindling, yes?
Similarly, today, I
was taking a walk,
and I saw this
enormous Redwood tree.
It's-- I don't know how
many centuries old it is,
but it's still growing
and growing and growing,
because there's conscious
life within that tree.
But when the conscious
life is no longer there,
it cannot grow.
The little flower,
there is consciousness
within that little flower that
makes it bloom and gives it
its fragrance.
So we see in our own
practical experience
how, wherever there is
consciousness, there's growth,
there's development.
So from a spiritual
perspective, it
is consciousness that is the
source of everything that
exists.
And there is an ultimate
Supreme consciousness that's
the source of everything.
Is there a recipe to keeping
focused on these higher
principles in our lives?
In our tradition, there's
three very important principles
that help us remain focused.
One is Satsang.
Satsang means to be
with enlightened people
and to be with people
who are striving
for enlightenment, to
help us remain focus,
to help inspire us.
It's very important
Who we associate,
what we associate
with very much influences the
values we have in our life.
If you put an iron rod
in fire, after time,
it becomes red
and hot like fire.
If you put that same iron
rod in ice, after some time
it becomes as cold as ice.
I know many people
who are helplessly
drug addicts and alcoholics.
And in Alcoholics Anonymous
or Narcotics Anonymous,
because they had an
assembly of people
with the common interests of
becoming sober and remaining
sober, they were able to
overcome those distractions.
In this world, people are so
much addicted to greed and envy
and selfishness and arrogance.
We need each other
to help, to actually
give the strength,
the clarity of vision,
so that we don't fall
into these trappings.
In a Redwood forest, the roots
underground are interconnected
and give support.
Every tree in the Redwood
forest is directly or indirectly
giving support to each other.
And even in the face of
earthquakes and massive storms,
they keep growing
together, because they
support each other.
Satsang is very important,
where we come together
to help each other
focus on that big fish,
on the higher principles that
are really of value in life
and help each other
to overcome and resist
falling into temptations
and fears that distract us
from our real purpose.
And putting some time of
day for a spiritual practice
to make that inner
connection is very important.
The other day, I was speaking
at the Apple Corporation.
And I was remembering
how in their computers
they have batteries.
And how long the battery
lasts is very important.
You have to keep
recharging that battery.
So similarly, in our
own spiritual batteries,
our own integrity and
focus, to recharge it
through proper company,
through our prayers,
through our meditation--
in our tradition,
we chant god's names--
it keeps us charged
with spiritual strength and with
a clear vision of what really
is important in our lives and
what we really want to achieve.
And then Sadachar.
Sadachar is integrating
the blessings
we receive through
the company we keep
and through our spiritual
practices in our life,
to live with character,
to live with integrity.
This human body, there are
various limbs and organs,
and each one has its
own unique function.
The heart is pumping the blood.
The brain has a function,
the lungs, the pancreas,
the kidneys.
One cannot do what
the other does.
They have different
shapes, different colors,
and very different functions.
What is a healthy body?
If the stomach is thinking,
I'm the one supplying food
to every part of the
body, I don't like you,
kidneys, I'm not going
to give you anything.
If the stomach thinks
like that, the whole body
becomes sick,
including the stomach.
Every part of the body
recognizes, appreciates,
and respects every
other part of the body.
So within this
social body, we have
engineers, farmers, scientists.
We have bankers.
We have people in politics.
There are so many
various professions.
We also have swamis and priests.
They are all serving
a particular function,
but with appreciation and
respect for the contribution
of each other.
We need farmers.
We need bankers.
Technology is
absolutely wonderful,
if it's utilized for
wonderful purpose.
Philosophy is wonderful, if it's
used for wonderful purposes.
So the principle of
dharma or spirituality
is to understand the difference
between material and spiritual.
Everything is potentially
spiritual, if we understand
its relationship
with the Supreme,
if we understand the
relationship we all have
with each other on that basis.
And just like that
knife analogy I
was giving, if we
recognize that, then we
can express the highest
dharma in whatever occupation
we may be in.
Sitting here today
is one of my dearest
friends and brothers, Gurudas.
And years ago, he was living
in John Lennon's estate
just outside of London.
This was in the 1960s.
John Lennon is from the Beatles.
And George Harrison
became very serious
about this bhakti yoga,
or Krishna consciousness.
And he came to our
guru Srila Prabhupada.
And he asked permission
to shave his head
and become a resident
of the ashram.
And Srila Prabhupada, our guru,
told him, you're a musician,
you have fame, you have
wealth, you're a Beatle.
You can serve better
by just doing it
with a spiritual purpose.
And he did.
And he affected more people
with spiritual values
than most-- any monk ever did.
So spiritual life is not
about changing our occupation.
It's about changing
our consciousness,
changing our values.
I know CEOs of corporations,
international corporations,
with families, who are really
saints, because they're not
trying to exploit people.
They have inner integrity.
They've developed and
excavated that inner love.
And they express it
through their work.
And it's beautiful.
GOPI KALLAYIL: And
with that, on behalf
of everyone here
and Google, I'd like
to thank Radhanath
Swami for spending time
with us, sharing his
incredible wisdom.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]